I'm pleased to announce that upon
completion of all the necessary checks
by the Federal Bureau of Investigation I
will send to the Senate the nomination
of Judge Sandra Day O'Connor of Arizona
Court of Appeals for confirmation as an
Associate Justice of the United States
Supreme Court Wow look at that history
that was President Ronald Reagan in 1981
announcing his decision to appoint
Sandra Day O'Connor as the first woman
to serve on the Supreme Court she
retired in 2006 to care for her husband
John after he was diagnosed with
Alzheimer's disease in a letter Tuesday
O'Connor announced she too has dementia
that remains grateful she wrote how
fortunate I feel to be an American and
to have been presented with the
remarkable opportunities available to
the citizens of our country I never
could have imagined that one day I would
become the first woman justice on the US
Supreme Court Sandra Day O'Connor's
youngest son Jay joins us this morning
here at the table good morning good
morning since we learned of your mom's
diagnosis she has been on the minds of
so many people how's she doing she's
doing fine she lives in Phoenix this was
an important moment for her to be open
with people about what her condition is
she wanted to share the news herself and
be transparent about it's a problem a
lot of people have and she wanted she
thought it would be helpful to get it
out in the public yeah but this is round
2 for the family you know because you
went through it with your dad and family
members have said this was her biggest
fear one of her greatest fears do you
recall what her reaction was when she
was diagnosed back in 2014 she didn't
want to believe it yeah she had seen how
hard it is in what happens to someone as
they progressed through the stages of
the disease and she really didn't want
to believe it and she had been her whole
life she has overcome so many obstacles
and I think she thought I can just power
through this and it turns out you can't
really power power through dementia and
alzheimerís yeah she's a fighter she
fought through cancer but you said that
you started noticing the family members
early warning signs when she would give
speeches and start repeating things we
did you'd have like we would you would
see we have a conversation with her and
it was that we would notice things that
most people wouldn't notice
you started to see these little things
and my mom would canal although I can't
remember that and so we saw the signs
and at some point she went in and had a
conversation with her doctor it is you
know just check things out and and the
diagnosis came back J when people lose
their parents particularly ones who live
these kinds of amazing and public lives
they sometimes say oh I wish I'd asked
them this in 2014 did you say you know
I'd like to ask mom about this or that
or the other thing well we've been able
to have a the whole time a lot of
conversations and so fortunately it's a
grits a gradual condition and so we
there's nothing really that we haven't
been able to ask her so she can still
communicate she knows who you are oh
absolutely yeah she loves the sense of
her day-to-day life yes she lives now
she also is mainly restricted to a
wheelchair now and so she's got a
mobility challenges so she lives in an
assisted living community where she can
she actually has friends living in the
same place with her and and she loves
having visitors loves having family
loves hearing the latest with the
grandkids and what they're up to and so
you can have a wonderful conversation
with her it's your short-term memory as
challenge these one of my favorite
stories though about your mom is that
when your dad had it and he was in a
facility he developed what they're
calling a romantic relationship with
someone else and that your mom was
actually supportive well what happens
it's not uncommon when people reach a
certain stage in their relationship if
they have these accidental or
unintentional relationships very
innocent it's almost like a little kid
relationship with a boy and girl and
there was a woman in the facility who he
had a nice relationship with and my mom
embraced it because it was a companion
it made him feel good and and so all of
us embraced it and I will never forget
my mom would go over to visit and
sometimes the three of them would be
sitting on the same bench together
passing the time my my dad is in the
middle it was really something you know
Jay one of the things that maria shriver
who's talked so much about Alzheimer's
is what a burden this is in some ways
for caregivers it's really tough on a
family how that you have two parents who
have suffered with dementia and
Alzheimer's are you doing we're doing
okay you know it's my mom is not only a
national treasure she is a family
treasure
so it's hard for all of us to see you're
kind of go through this it's a
progressive condition that keeps on
getting worse over time but my mom has
handled everything with grace and
dignity and you know we're just so proud
of everything that she's done in her
life and who she is as a person
so we feel honored to be able to help
her at this time when she needs help
just as she was a caregiver for my dad
are you are you and your siblings
worried about yourselves
well it's not a good thing to have two
parents who have dementia so you never
know definitely the odds get higher so
you got to eat your veggies and we're
all keeping our Russell sprouts are
amazing a lesson from mom the judge no
you know listen every all of us this
issue is so important to Americans in
general so it's important that the
research still happen and every family
will benefit from from the research that
comes out have the other justices
reached out since the diagnosis I don't
know if you saw it but there was an
incredible series of tributes that went
out from all the current and past
justices who my mom ever served with
that went out at the end of Tuesday and
the tributes were really wonderful and
meant a lot to her and so she's already
seen those tributes and it's been a lot
to her she mastered work-life balance
never missed your summer camp drop off I
love that absolutely you sat down we
asked you did she watch the Cavanaugh
hearings and you said no not really so
that's why we're thinking of her yeah
very much thank you thank you